[Music]
what was it like you know being raised
in this very unconventional lifestyle
you're not a normal human if if you
can't go out into the world Jada
pinkett-smith getting real with her kids
Jaden and Willow about growing up in
Hollywood on her Facebook watch a series
read Table Talk the red table is a place
of testimony you know and a place where
we get to share our story share our
experiences and get to really talk and
spill our truth in a very raw way the
family got incredibly candid about life
inside what Jada calls the bubble both
Jaden and Willow said they had no idea
anyone grew up differently even their
own parents you and daddy never told us
really what type of world you guys came
from yeah we just thought that you guys
just sprouted up out of the ground
yeah you know I'm saying the kids that
went on to call out their mom and dad
for starting them in the industry too
young what is the part that you think
daddy and I have a difficult time
connecting to you with I mean I only
have one like really terrible experience
which is which is wit my hair Jada
teared up and she explained that she
only pushed them so they could have a
better life than she did when you become
a parent you have these huge ideals even
for yourself because we all are coming
into parenting with our own childhood
traumas and you can't your kids are
gonna have their burdens and even though
I see how it might have hurt you it's
what I knew yeah
and there will be more where that came
from Jada teased a still to come
appearance by her hubby Will Smith when
et visited the read table back in April
yeah I promise I'll stop will and I
actually gonna have a very interesting
conversation about how our journey in
regards to transforming a marriage into
a life partnership an understanding of
that and understanding more of that you
know you come to the episode but it's
gonna be a really powerful discussion
and how my mother and how willow and
Jaden the whole family has been involved
in this transformation so
[Music]